Jessica and Jessica's going to tell us
about replicability in learning
thank you very much for the introduction
um thanks for the amazing Workshop
thanks to all the organizers
yeah so today I'm going to be talking
about joint work with a bunch of people
several of whom are in the audience so
this is when you work with Mark Bunn
Marco vivardi Max Hopkins who's a grad
student at UCSD Russell Rex also a grad
student Tony and sachet is a grad
student at bu
um so before we get into uh definition I
sort of just want to talk informally
about what we're going to mean by
replicability and why it's important
so this is you know ideally what the
scientific method looks like
um right so uh in our little caricature
here we have a scientist uh here it's Dr
mcnibbles and Dr mcnibbles has some
hypothesis that they want to test right
so they um have some hypothesis that
like drug a is going to be an effective
treatment for disease B
and so what are they going to do they're
going to design an experiment to collect
data and then they're going to perform
some sort of hypothesis testing analysis
on that data conclude whether or not
drug a is in fact an effective treatment
for to csb and then they're going to
report that to the broader scientific
community
so if what we're really doing when we
perform these experiments and these
analyzes is capturing and enduring real
world phenomena then it should be the
case that another team of scientists
could come along follow Dr mcnibbles's
experimental procedure collect their own
data perform the same analysis and
obtain the same results right that's
ideally what we'd like to have happen
and that's what we're going to mean when
we talk about replicability
but as many of you may know uh the real
world looks very different from this
idealized picture from the previous
slide um so there's
the survey uh real quick just to give
you an idea of how dismal the situation
is there's a survey published in nature
in 2016 by Baker just serving scientists
from a variety of fields about failures
of replication right so I feel like the
social sciences in particular get a bad
rap for failures of replication but this
survey was for you know what we might
call like the heart Sciences so I don't
know if you can see it but the they
surveyed chemists biologists folks in
physics and Engineering medicine arson
environmental sciences and then others
um and uh they're red bars here are
scientists who had failed to replicate
somebody or uh reproduce somebody else's
results
and you can see that like you know well
over 50 in most disciplines had failed
um to reproduce the finding and then
this lighter pink bar here is how many
had failed to reproduce their own
findings right and that's not great
um and if you know this is just one
survey
um maybe you don't you know trust one
particular survey so much but if you go
to the Wikipedia page on the replication
crisis you can have a very bad afternoon
if that's your idea of a good time yes
fail to replicate like single
experiments
yeah yeah so it's sort of maybe not
super compelling as you imagine people
might be performing many experiments is
that the point yeah yeah
so the question was have you ever
um you know is this is a saying anything
about like the fraction of experiments
that you've built up okay no the survey
was just asking have you ever looked
once failed to
um
okay
all right so
in our work we're going to Forex in
previous work um
with Russell Rex Tony
um we tried to introduce a definition to
capture
um algorithms that replicate
and what we're going to mean by that is
a randomized algorithm a will be row
replicable if it's the case that notably
for any distribution d
over some domain X if we draw two
samples from this distribution and run
the algorithm twice more on each sample
and hold the randomness fixed between
both runs we should get exactly the same
output except with probability row
so this is going to be like the notion
we're going to be discussing I always
discuss a number of other stability
Notions but this is maybe one of the
more novel ones we'll be discussing over
the course of this talk so if there are
questions yeah what's m
um and here so we're going to imagine
that uh the algorithm a takes a sample
from a distribution that will be of some
size and so you can imagine if you have
a learning algorithm
um M might vary depending on your target
accuracy parameters and things like that
so I guess when S2 are vectors of
samples or something yeah yeah we're
taking we're drawing like multiple times
great questions
this is not assumed to be a decision
algorithm it's not a thing to be a
decision algorithm I think that in the
case that a is a decision algorithm
um this particular definition is
particularly well motivated um so to
maybe anticipate questions that I have
gotten a lot about this work is you know
why why do we have this strong
requirement that we're getting exactly
the same output right it's like what if
they just get two good outputs
um in the case especially if you have a
decision problem well what is you know
what is your job that's to be post it's
going to be zero or one so we only get
exactly the same decision but we're not
assuming this
other questions yeah right so for the r
being the same in both like this is you
choose a random R and you feed the exact
same one each time to both of them yes
okay
okay is this like a weakening of pseudo
determinism oh it's great
um thanks
so it is inspired my work on student
journalism I'll um maybe point out some
differences between definition so
um so yeah
um in the case of pseudo determinism
what we want is for to be a case that
for all inputs most random strings will
yield the same output
uh but notably what we're re-randomizing
in that case is coming from a fixed
distribution right the uniform
distribution over random strings here
what we're re-randomizing is coming from
a like arbitrarily behaved distribution
so we have to work for all distributions
so that's one significant difference
um another is the quantification over
over the input right so this is going to
be average case over yeah
yes but it is inspired very much by by
the definition of pseudodramastic
algorithms yes in some sense it's a dual
notion in pseudo-determinism you want
the uh output to depend on the input but
not the randomness here we're saying we
want the output to depend on the
randomness but not the inputs
is
okay so a typically I guess in the
learning setting or an algorithm that
works for
um I think you're gonna check that sort
of family where
um we'll have Target parameters Maybe
not maybe for applicability but maybe
also for accuracy those will fix M and
then
but what we will show um I guess in a
second uh how the replicability
parameter row is going to a fact
great okay so that's a brief aside also
because you were brought this up and so
in case anyone saw the
um saw previous talks or is outside of
this paper and in stock uh 2021 there
has been a rebranding
um so this this is replicability
previously known as reproducibility so I
just want to to call that out real quick
in case anyone's confused the ACM put
out some some guidance uh clarifying
distinctions between replicability and
reproducibility
um where replicability is fixed to say
that a two team of scientists can
collect their own data and obtain the
same results whereas reproducibility
means that you use the same data that
the previous team used and can obtain
the same results and so because we're
resampling our input data we thought our
notion was more aligned with
replicability and we didn't want to
fight the ACM so we decided we just
confuse people instead and change the
name
so I just wanted to have that off okay
great
um so we were inspired by this uh this
work on pseudo deterministic algorithms
um but there's actually at the same time
a team of Google um gazi Kumar and
manarangsi introduced
um essentially equivalent notion called
pseudo global stability
um
they use this in their their work on
um user level privacy and they suited
global stability as they Define it's a
little bit different that they have two
parameters they sort of separate
separate out row into a failure
probability over random strings and
failure probability over the sample
and this in turn was a generalization of
global stability just introduced by
Moran and their work characterizing
private pack learnability by little
Stone dimension
so today I'm going to talk about
connections between replicability and
other important Notions or stability
Notions in learning and statistical
analysis
so we're going to talk about
reputability and how it relates to
differential privacy it relates to Max
information and how it relates to
one-way perfect generalization
possible for today but first I want us
to get a sort of flavor of replicable
algorithms to sort of see
um like how they work
um they're sort of maybe one weird trick
that at a high level underlies most of
our algorithmic results and so I want to
show you this trick so you can sort of
have that in the back of your head if
you're wondering how do we get
replicable algorithms in practice
then we'll talk about the connections
we'll Define all these relevant Notions
I just showed on the previous slide
we'll discuss a few applications and
then actually you know talk about how
we're going to to prove for how we're
going to draw some of these arrows in
the diary
so let's get into it by showing how we
can make reproducible statistical or how
we can simulate a reproducible
statistical statistical very Oracle for
those who aren't familiar it's a
statistical query model was introduced
by Kearns to capture from a pack
learning under random classification
noise and the idea here as opposed to
like the standard pack learning Paradigm
where your learner gets access to
labeled examples here the learner's only
going to get access to statistical
information about the underlying
distribution okay so the learner is
going to have some sort of query so
submit it to the Oracle and then the
Oracle will give them something that is
close to the expectation of that query
over the target distribution up to some
additive tolerance parameter Tau
foreign
we can Implement a statistical query
Oracle using a large enough sample right
so we have these queries a concentrate
if we have an IID sample then we can use
concentration bounds to say that okay I
can hit whatever additive tolerance I
want by just taking my sample to be
large enough
this won't work for us in the case of
replicability right because we're we're
in this previous non-replicable
statistical query Oracle setting we're
using or a sample to empirically compute
the quantity that we want to return
right so our answer is one two very much
dependent on the sample
so you know say the expectation of the
query is really the screen dot here and
we're going to draw some sample
and return A1 based on the sample S1
that we drew
well maybe it's an underestimate for
this particular sample but we draw
another sample and we get an
overestimate right clearly the blue dot
is not the same as the Green Dot and so
we will not be replicable
this two Tau interval and which are our
empirical estimates could fall so what
are we going to do about this
we're going to start by partitioning the
range the zero one interval in two
sub-intervals of width Alpha
and now we're going to Define canonical
representatives of this partition so
we'll take the midpoints of each
sub-interval
and now when we compute
our empirical estimate rather than
returning those commit itself we're just
going to return the canonical
representative from the interval that we
fell in
okay so now in this this pretty picture
here hey like our two impair customers
are in the same interval we return the
same midpoint and we're applicable great
um but we're not done yet right
um there this is the sort of a nice case
where the expectation landed in the
middle of an interval but what if it's
actually fell on the boundary or close
to a boundary between two intervals and
some samples will land in this region
some will put us over here and again we
won't be replicable
but we haven't used our random string
yeah right so we haven't actually used
Randomness so what we're going to do is
we're going to choose the first place
that we draw a boundary using our random
string we're going to pick some value
from uh in between 0 and Alpha draw the
first boundary there and that will and
then draw every subsequent boundary
after with Alpha and that will let us
randomize where these boundaries fall
okay so some choices of boundaries will
be good for evocability some will be bad
but we can now bound the probability
that we picked a bad starting place
um as follows right so there's this
two-tau region that we want to avoid
with our choice of boundary we're
choosing the boundary from a range zero
Alpha and so we can you know by by
choosing appropriate parameters we can
hit whatever Target replicability
parameter you like foreign
[Music]
just using a vanilla lsh is that the the
value you have to might not be
associated with any kind of uh
with any kind of interval
um yeah so we want to actually like have
a an lsh that's actually mapping you to
a point that's nearby so you really want
the domain in domains to be the same
yeah
you can think of this as one particular
Construction
of lsh for that additional property
great question any other questions
tolerance
uh yeah so you do you mean
um or maybe I'll go on to what I was
going to say next to you because see if
that answers your question which is that
um because we are arounding to sort of
the
um the canonical representative for
Interval but we can only actually have
accuracy order Alpha right is that what
you're getting at here
yeah
um
right so
um so in this case yeah our tolerance
parameter is going to be fixed
um by the by this Alpha parameter uh
and the idea here is that okay if we
have a particular Target accuracy we'll
we'll pick Alpha to be that and then we
have a Target applicability parameter
um and that's going to be this two-tau
over Alpha right where tau is sort of
the tolerance of the non-replicable
statistical query Oracle that we're
simulating and so we'll need a larger
sample
right and in order to uh balance these
parameters
but they'll they'll be polynomial and
we'll end up with
an inverse quadratic dependence on
replicability in the sample complexity
of like the you know one over task
squared that you would expect from from
just doing The Parables
um maybe you'll guess this is a sec but
like is
the idea of like application I guess to
a science experiment is you would use
this mechanism and then you publish the
random seed and someone else is supposed
to exactly copy that or okay exactly so
if someone wants to obtain obtain your
results today and you would publish yeah
the randomness that you used and then
they know that if they go out and use
that custom reviews
example they can
so this is for that single way
it's for a single query um so uh record
really will will compose for adaptive
queries though and so you can use this
to develop your favorite statistical
query algorithm yeah
does that include like hyper parameter
tuning so so to his question if if I
search a grid of have you have you
thought through this specific example by
searching a grid of hyper parameters
with a canonical representation of each
hyper parameter now maybe I could make
training like large State models
Randomness that went into that
interesting so um so okay so so what
you're proposing is
um
I guess like at a high level like if you
can model each step of the analysis
process by a replicable procedure then
then yes by composition you should be
able to say it but the
um yeah that's the composition of all of
these choices
will also be replicable I'm not sure
exactly I don't think I yeah have a
clear enough picture of the the flow of
hyper perimeter tuning in my head to
actually be able to sail yeah yeah but
yes I think if you can model each stack
as a replica procedure
and that makes sense so like maybe the
case where you want to redo some of the
randomness
like maybe keep the first half
yeah yeah so so you're imagining
um
that's
so I think that's why you can sort of
treat those coins is like maybe part of
the sample as well so we're just
imagining the the pr like the the public
Randomness is going into this second
perimeter and then you're resampling the
rest and so I think what if you only
publish part of the randomness
well it isn't I maybe I misunderstanding
the the question but since we're we're
resampling everything else right we're
sorry something from the oh okay symbol
but then you're also sampling from the
same distribution or for over Randomness
right so you can
[Music]
and I should also oh sorry yeah yeah so
we showed that
um for replicability in itself releasing
all the randomness is the optimal thing
to do
um
but
efficiency and communication there might
be a reason to uh reduce the the amount
of Revenue
uh we haven't really investigated that
that was actually in the in the Grossman
Lou
paper
determinism for small space computation
that was kind of their main point is to
minimize the amount of Randomness you
release I also maybe piggyback on that
just observe uh that I I believe it's
also the case that if you sort of relax
this worst case distributional
assumption and start introducing
smoothness properties you can also
reduce the amount of Randomness required
so
um this sort of trick that we did here
right like the the thing I call the one
weird trick is that we discretize we
used our Randomness to pick a random
disparatization of the output space and
then we snapped our empirical estimates
onto that that grid
um and so if you have like maybe
smoothness and maybe you can take a
wider grid and so you don't need as much
random instruction
okay
so in the grossmanian newspaper they get
what you get here
um so we we don't have any
it's like okay I guess like you're a
number of bits of Randomness is going to
be described
Alpha and so against
great so uh there's a lot to talk about
so any other questions about the
definition
um I would love uh to hear something
from you but it sounds great offline
I also point out that we um this is
essentially quite a separate
complexities and we also have
um lower bounds showing that this
inverse quadratic dependence on rows
sorry
okay so back to other Notions of
stability
and drawing all the arrows in this
diagram
um so first I want to actually you know
tell you what all of these definitions
means we can see why we think they may
or may not be related
so let's start with Epsilon Delta
differential privacy okay so the idea
with differential privacy is we want to
limit the amount of information that our
analysis is going to like leak about
individuals in our data set okay so in
this case
um we're going to be worst case over
data sets there's not like an average
case assumption here we're saying you're
differentially private if for all
neighboring data sets
um where neighboring means we've swapped
out
individual so uh in this little sketch
here like you know we can imagine two
neighboring data sets uh this one has a
bunch of people in particular it has
Marco chromosino here and then in S
Prime we have swapped out uh Marco for
Mark button just picking on two people
in the audience
um
uh but otherwise the data sets are the
same
this was introduced by a dwarf insurance
and should be the case that if we we run
our analysis on these neighboring data
sets that the distributions over outputs
that we get
um are close
okay so any questions about privacy
so in particular in this
and it doesn't matter
like some straight distance between
very adversarial examples
great Fair observation
all right
um
okay so moving on to uh Max information
so this has been introduced by her phone
number
Roth we'll work on um
data analysis
um and we're no longer going to be uh
worst case here
um we and we're not going to care so
much about individuals as we care about
samples so
um next information is going to
um informally found how much you can
learn about the sample
from looking at the output of the
algorithm run on that sample right so
the idea is if you're not leaking too
much information your output about the
specific sample
um then the joint distribution over
samples and outputs of your algorithm on
that sample should be sort of close to
the product distribution
um between uh the samples and algorithm
run on samples drawn from d
okay so you know we need to leak some
information about the sample because
we're trying to learn something about
the distribution from which the sample
came and so we're instead just trying to
to say okay like the correlation between
the output and the specific sample we
used to obtain that output should not be
cheaper
foreign
there's one way perfect generalization
and this is kind of similar and again
we're trying to say that our the
particular sample we use is not going to
um be revealed or like we're not going
to learn too much about it from the
output of the algorithm
so in particular here we're imagining
that there's
um some distribution that will be
induced by the district the target
distribution we're trying to learn over
right so it'll be a distribution say
over like good outputs of the algorithm
a and it should be the case that if we
look at the distribution of outputs of a
once we've fixed the sample but we're
allowed to to re-randomize so the
randomness of a that distribution should
be sort of close
to this idealized distribution that of
outputs that we we imagined that we're
getting from if it helps to sort of
ground you you can imagine it being the
distribution over all runs of a where
both the sample and the randomness are
we randomized
so that's sort of uh
we're saying once we fixed the sample
we're not changing the distribution too
much from this idea
and
um let's say this is introduced by
Cummings Nissan Roth Wu and also
obsidian formed
I already talked about reputability so
any questions about these definitions
so
why do we care about connecting them
other than you know it lets us draw nice
diagrams and we do love drawing nice
diagrams like what you know like what
what's going to motivate us wanting
connections between these various
emotions
and so here I want to talk about
um one of our applications and we'll go
back for a second so
um what this diagram lets us do amongst
many things is if you know we start here
the central privacy we can convert to an
algorithm with bounded Max information
we can refer to a one-way generalizing
convert back uh or convert to a replica
algorithm and then obtain a
differentially private algorithm right
so we can convert differential privacy
to differential privacy which may sound
like a joke but is actually useful in
the following instance and that's
privacy amplification yes
complexity of the algorithm that's being
transformed so some of these arrows are
going to follow by explicit
Transformations so we're going to follow
definitionally
um and so there will be a sample
complexity blow up
but notably like you walk this whole
circle and you'll get a
um
N squared over Epsilon
the the top the arrow
and students only if you do not put
these randomness
um oh so so what we're imagining what
we're going to do here is show that
essentially you can
um so I think I think what you're saying
if it's true and that we're going to
take a reputable algorithm we're going
to run it a whole bunch of times
um directly to ourselves so yeah we're
not going to release Randomness but
we're going to use the fact that they're
sort of phenomenal representatives for a
given output string to give us privacy
I think just just to be clear we're
saying there exists an algorithm
of property implies there existing
algorithm not necessarily the same
algorithm is going to
um be be
have the property
going back to why we would ever want to
convert privacy and privacy
um so
if we start with an Epsilon Delta
differentially private algorithm
um
generally what we'll want in particular
and we want all these parameters to be
small but in particular we want the
Delta parameter to be very very small
right because if Delta is large then
um seeing a particular output can be
very informative about the sample
um and so we'd like to just Delta to be
very small in particular we'd sort of
like it to be like uh you know inverse
exponential in the
um in the sample cells
uh but
um what if we start with something that
says it has like a polynomial
relationship instead there are privacy
amplification techniques that rely on
taking a larger sample and then
subsampling
um so here you know if we if we just
took a larger data set in both cases if
we sub-sampled then like maybe we don't
even
end up subsampling
Marco at all and then when we you know
look at the two runs of our algorithm
they'll be exactly the same because we
actually looked at the same data sets so
we can take a larger data set subsample
from it and improve our privacy
parameters but this actually isn't going
to be enough to get us from
um you know the regime uh if you know
we're in this polynomial regime to this
exponential regime that we'd really like
um so our tracing through our diagram
actually allows you to obtain privacy
amplification uh for
um for Delta to get to sort of the
target primaries we'd really like
so amongst other applications
um we can also
use like all of the work that's been
done for for differential private
algorithms and apply that to
replicability right so replicability
sort of seems like this very strong ask
from an algorithm and that we want
exactly the same output not just you
know sort of close distributions
um but then we can say okay well you
know we already know how to do tons of
things privately and then we can you
know again features through our diagram
we can now do them replicably in
particular we can get a replicable pact
learning for finite hypothesis classes
um so this will follow from results of
uh Lee Nissan uh Russ gold nikova and
Smith which showed how to obtain uh
Epsilon zero differentially a private
Alpha accurate agnostic learners for any
sort of finite hypothesis class with
this logarithmic dependence on the size
of the hypothesis class
when you get our transformation and you
can you know you get this quadratic blow
up but we we now have example efficient
replicable learning
I should note that we can actually
improve this dependence on Alpha in the
realizable case by a direct proof
um but it's still cool that we can get
this just by you know locking a diagram
um so now that we know why we care or
some of the reasons we might care about
Transformations let's actually draw some
of these arrows
um and because some of these
Transformations might be efficient
um some won't actually entail a
transformation at all and some are
inefficient I'm introducing the
following star system to to know which
ones are efficient and which ones are
efficient for the idea of being a star
means you're efficient and then the most
efficient way to become a thing is to
already be that thing and so you get two
stars if no transformation is required
foreign
privacy
um I don't want to go into this
transformation too much because I want
to be able to talk a little bit about
the ones I think are a bit more
interesting
um but I will at least observe
um that both of them have
uh you know like modest blow-ups in the
sample complexity size
and the idea in both cases
um is going to be sort of the same so I
can maybe give you an idea if you're
curious about how we're going to convert
from applicability to this
generalization notion or differential
privacy notion
the idea is we're going to take we're
going to start by populating a row of a
table here by picking a random string
okay and then we're going to
pick a whole bunch of samples from our
distribution run our replicable
algorithm on the string we chose for
this row and all the different samples
if the particular string we chose was
good for replicability which will be a
good probability then there should be
some output in this row here that is you
know there should be like a majority
output or there should be a very
frequent output okay and so on for each
of the rows maybe some string is way bad
and there won't be any clear majority
but it should be the case that for most
of the rows there's a majority output
and in both of these Transformations
what we're going to do is preferentially
output
the the results that we see with highest
highest frequency so what exactly that
means will differ in both
Transformations but that's sort of the
idea
so to get from Epsilon differential
privacy to Epsilon Delta Max information
most of the work for system of the
workbooks are already done for us
um in this work of Roger Schrock Smith
stacker
um
they show that Epsilon Delta
differential privacy actually just
implies Max information for a particular
setting of parameters okay so if we're
at fundamental differentially private
um then that same algorithm will uh
have this Max information these Max
information parameters
um which is a little bit annoying
because they have have these like M
terms that maybe we don't like right
like maybe maybe we want something
tighter that's not actually going to
depend on the sample complexity of the
algorithm that we started with
but then we can use this sort of
sub-sampling procedure that we just
talked about
all right so we know that if we just
take a large enough sample particularly
if we take you know we blow up our
sample by
um
another Factor m
so we can perform the subsampling and
then get the Epsilon Delta differential
differential of privacy parameters
um compared to the sample complexity
that allow us to get maximum information
parameters in particular we can end up
with something
um you can end up with like Epsilon
Epsilon Max information so long as we
started with a small enough Delta but
again like it's typically Delta is going
to be very very small in terms of the
the sample complexity and so this is a
very modest assumption this isn't a
particularly strange
oops that's how we're getting from
privacy to Max information
and again this is just this is a
two-star transformation so it's my food
transformation just follows definition
now to to help from Max information to
one-way perfect generalization we have
something else that just follows
definitionally right so these these two
definitions were sort of similar in the
first place right we're saying okay we
want to
um we want to say that the the sample
um I guess the output of an algorithm
run on a particular sample is not too
informative about the sample that we
used
and so by picking
our ideal distribution that we're
comparing to to be this definition that
I or this distribution I talked about
before
um
you can show that this follows
definitionally right so again we're
going to imagine uh Sim D in the
definition of perfect generalization to
be the distribution over outputs of a
given samples from a target distribution
D and you know from randomness
and then again if uh the output of a is
not too informative about the sample
then it's going to follow that we're
also converted
so these parameters again are uh you
just want to be a little bit clearer
about how they're transforming so if we
started with Epsilon Delta Max
information then we're going to get root
Delta 2 Epsilon root Delta one-way
perfect generalization
great and now we come to the problem
child of our diagram you'll notice there
are no stars on this Arrow
um so this is the transformation from
one way perfect generalization to
replicability
and
um
there is a construction uh that allows
us to transform from from one to the
other but it is not always going to be
efficient and in fact I think like the
the best procedures we have for this one
only work for finite range and are
exponential
um and and so we don't necessarily
um which is actually we necessarily
don't have a public photography exists
efficient Transformations from one-way
perfect generalization
um the connection however the
statistical connection utilizes a
technique called correlated sampling and
I want to talk a little bit about that
so you can see like where the bottleneck
is coming in
what is a correlated sampler
related sampler is some algorithm that's
going to take a representation of the
distribution that we want to sample from
here we'll call that QD
and in particular we're going to require
that it has finite support
okay so this is going to throw that
finite support restriction into our
diagram and so we're only going to be
able to
way around if the output of a is finite
and we'll let already know some random
string and correlated sampler is going
to take in its representation of the
distribution and the random string and
it will output something in the support
of the distribution it should be
sampling from
and it should be the case if we're
actually a good correlated sampler that
we are in fact sampling from the target
distribution right so we output an
element y with the same probability it
appears
indeed and then the correlated part is
coming from the fact that if we fix the
randomness between two runs of our
correlated sampler on two different
distributions as input right so we're
going to get the two different
representations two different
distributions fix the randomness we
should still get exactly the same
element out of our correlated sampler
except with probability that's
proportional to the total variation
distance between those two distributions
okay so if we're given exactly the same
distribution or something that's very
very close since little variation
distance and with high probability we
should get the same element out of our
correlated sampler
and B Prime has the same support
yes yeah so because it's finite we can
just like take the union of both of them
and say okay no that was really your
support all along so the assumption is
that the collaborative sensor takes
a representation in R and outputs
can you see a finite range I mean like
constant size or just finite technique
okay
the size no
no
um yeah I mean like
it's really I'm not actually going to
talk about like how to say shape or lead
Samplers so this is just sort of like
definitionally we just wanted to be
about that outside
all right so what are we going to use
this for the example for
so we can imagine
uh in the setup of replicability we want
to take two samples from the same
distribution and get the same output
right
um and so we can imagine all right
here's our um
here's our algorithm on some sample s
Prime
um and we uh yeah that's the
distribution over outputs in in either
case
and
if we sample if we use our correlated
sample sampler to sample from the
outputs of either of these distributions
where again the distribution is fixing s
and then randomizing the internal
randomness of a
um we'll get we'll get some sort of
output right and what we want to say is
that okay our correlated sampler
um is going to give us exactly the same
outputs we want to we want to be able to
say something about these two
distributions right we want to be able
to say oh they're actually close and
total variation distance so our
correlated sampler is actually going to
give us exactly the same output and then
we'll be replicable okay
and that's what this one-way perfect
generalization allows us to say right so
we're going to say okay well there is
this distribution some D
um that uh we were close to regardless
of the sample that we fixed right so we
fixed sample we get something that's
close to
um this idealized distribution and
because they're both close they must be
close to each other and so a correlated
sampler will give us the same output
with high probability
great
so again this is like the the biggest
issue here is implementing correlated
sampling okay so again we're going to
need to restrict ourselves to algorithms
with finite domain and then we need some
sort of efficient way of carrying out
this procedure
yeah
well so you might ask
um is this just are we just bad at our
jobs right like that can we just like
not come up with a good correlate
sampler did we not try hard enough
um is there in fact some way that we can
make every step of this
this diagram computationally efficient
and the answer is no we we did try
um and you assuming public key
cryptography um or I should say like
under some standard public key
cryptographic assumptions
we're able to show that there are
problems you can solve efficiently with
differential privacy that you cannot
solve efficiently using replicability
great
um
um so you you they're sort of General
assumptions and then you can instantiate
them with like ggm if you like we
essentially need a re-randomizability
the idea here is we're going to have
some sort of Promise problem
um where you have like a distribution
over encryptions of zero distributions
over encryptions of one I can and the
problem is to Output
um an encryption of like the majority
bit that's encrypted from your sample
you can do this privately if you have a
re-randomizable encryption scheme
because I can just pick one at random
re-randomize it and not put that but if
I could do this replicably then I mean
there must be some canonical encryption
of of the majority a bit and canonical
encryptions are generally bad for
um in CPA security so yeah so it's just
re-randomizability and then
many of us
well okay so
um right under standard Republic
assumptions there will be an inefficient
step in this diagram on the other hand
if one with functions don't exist
um there actually always exists in
efficient correlated Samplers so we give
a construction for okay if you can just
invert all of the functions you can do
this correlated sampling efficiently but
there is a sort of Gap in these
assumptions right so we
um we don't really know okay is it one
is it you know mini Crypt or crypto uh
okay
um so that's sort of the the map of
these relationships between
um civilian Notions and again like here
is the
um the instructive example complexities
so it's each step and so again we see
that you're going through
I'd rather clog whenever talked to over
Epsilon blow up in in terms so this is
fairly efficient except for you know
computational efficiency and cool that's
all I wanted to talk about for these
connections I do want to say a couple of
words about future and ongoing work
um so this is a question okay like what
about correlated sampling for uh for
infinite domains right um
about so far we only know how to do for
for finite domains would be great if we
could say something for
and also going back to original
motivation right which was fixing
science
um it would be really great if we could
do practical replicable hypothesis
testing right so we're sort of getting
part of the way there with our
replicable statistical queries
um but because of the the sample
complexity lower bound we're kind of
asking in this case scientists to like
collect way way more data than they were
previously and that can be you know an
issue in practice and so is there some
sort of
um you know is there some sort of
setting or some particular formulation
of this problem where we can get around
our lower bound
I'm also interested in applications to
reinforcement learning in particular
when looking at this with Marcel hozing
at UPenn
so if we you know want to adapt this
replicability something to to
reinforcement learning we can imagine
samples rather than coming IED from sort
of distribution we're trying to learn on
we can imagine our samples as being the
state that we move to when we are in
some State and take some action
we can you know we will want to be
replicable in the sense that if we got
different transitions we ended up in
different states after making the same
choices that we should still be able to
converge on exactly the same policy
after some you know like polynomial
number of steps
I'm also interested in exploring
relaxations of our definition for other
settings right I mean we have this very
strong ask of equivalence of the output
and we are able to show all these
connections to other like very
reasonable Notions of stability but we
might also ask like what if we don't
care about like syntactic equivalents
right what if we care about functional
equivalence
um so I'm interested in looking at
relaxations of this definition we want
to obtain algorithms that output models
that make these same decisions on like
say all but an Epsilon fraction of their
inputs
foreign
possible
so
um I guess I guess you could say like
through privacy
right
um
even though your connections are not
coefficient
still recover
y
yeah okay meaning like actual
constructive
all right and just a natural place
yes
things from privacy so you know we have
a lot of lower bounds for
um uh like thresholds I guess
um depend on the size of the domain
operation
is the application like a science
um when is the idea so like you do an
experiment using one of these mechanisms
to like produce your statistics and
release the coins the the idea is that
someone
does the same experiment on the same
points would be able to identify that
their data is different or like like I
guess what I'm trying to understand like
the
like what is the confidence someone gets
from like reproducing experiment using
this mechanism like in I don't know if
this makes sense oh you know I think
okay so if maybe there are a couple of
questions that you you could be asking
and maybe one I'll say is
um is like one of the benefits
definitely uh to to using a replica
algorithm for data analysis
um is I guess I sort of like narrowing
the attack surface of failures of
applicability in a sense so I can know
that if I fail to replicate for some
reason it's not because there was a
statistical goodness sample so in some
sense it's like
um in one sentence both like assisting
replication efforts and say okay as long
as you publish the randomness you should
get this probability
um but it's also yeah sort of saying
okay like look elsewhere for four
failures of replication
take time
yeah let's uh thank you
[Music]